[Música]
[Aplausos]
la deliciosa
e
y ahora es bastante
a este ritmo 10 años algunos años
puedo escuchar modelos de aprendizaje de
volaris de marketing
mis otros
y hablar siempre de uno no siempre es
fácil pero si estoy aquí
e
y esas cosas 5
yo soy una persona
no tanto
una función
era
bueno
puede abrir el administrador
o
será eso
los animales y quitar yo siempre estaba
como me trataban de pasar lo que pasó si
hasta los tres años
[Música]
yo
y conocí a carlos
y esas cosas
y yo con todo el día
en contratarlos el tercer día beber
también está con él
como no sé se sienten
mi familia
dijo
[Música]
de todos los hijos tienes que estar
exponiendo que tienes que soportar
muchas cosas de tu cuerpo
y aceptar eso es muy difícil
brutal
así conozco muchas personas con esta
ansiedad
con todo
carlos
y me dijo esa pregunta
y le dije
10 19
cuándo
x
no iba a pasar
y dónde empieza este proceso
como terapéutico
pero para mí esas cosas
y creo que muchas mujeres nos atrevemos
a decir esto
porque si esto es una pregunta abierta
es porque siempre es un territorio
aunque no existe
acaso no poseen madre en las maneras no
conocen más mal estos proyectos madre de
insulina
los chicos no puede existir
senador madre al mío
es el presente
es muy
pero decir escribir un libro
y lo muy posible esto frente a lo que
están
es para que sean dos
porque si no tienen varios capítulos de
invisibles sociales no
con hombres sensibles
totalmente
jóvenes
entonces lo hice y no sé mucho menos dos
personas más gracias
entre ellos cosas como esta
no
una mujer
s
u otro misionero se lo tuyo de la gente
hola
aquí
y siempre creativo
no tengo yo
y
no no no
[Música]
y que puedes llegar que puede ser
perfecto
también es diferente
a mí me tocó elección fue una decisión
[Aplausos]